ONE.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
AMAZING.
AND "NEW DAY" CONTINUES RIGHT
NOW.
>>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>> ALL RIGHT, GOOD MORNING TO
OUR VIEWER HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IS FRIDAY, OCTOBER 1st.
WE DO HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
WHAT COULD BE THE FIRST PILL
USED TO TREAT COVID-19.
THIS COULD BECOME A REALITY AND
VERY SOON.
DRUGMAKER MERCK ANNOUNCED THIS
MORNING THAT ITS ANTIVIRAL DRUG
CUSTOMERS THE RISK OF
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COVID IN HALF.
>> MERCK HAS PAUSED ITS TRIAL,
AND PLANS TO ASK FOR EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIZATION.
NOW IT IS IMPORTANT HERE TO NOTE
THAT THIS IS MEANT FOR PATIENTS
WHO ARE ALREADY INFECTED WITH
COVID.
NOT A REPLACEMENT FOR A VACCINE.
>> DR. SANJAY GUPTA HERE WITH ME
NOW.
THIS FEELS LOOK A BIG DEAL.
>> YEAH, THIS COULD BE A BIG
DEAL.
WE'RE GETTING ALL THE
INFORMATION FROM THE COMPANY
RIGHT NOW.
IT HAS GOT TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT EVERYONE KNOWS AND
LEARNED ABOUT OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THIS EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
APPLICATION MEANS THE FDA WILL
NOW LOOK AT THIS, BUT AS, YOU
KNOW, AS YOU MENTIONED, THIS
TRIAL WAS PAUSED BECAUSE AN
INDEPENDENT GROUP OF ADVISERS
BASICALLY LOOKS AT THE TRIAL
RESULTS AND SAYS, SOMETHING'S
GOING ON HERE.
>> SOMETHING GOOD IS GOING ON
HERE.
SO MUCH SO WE DON'T THINK IT IS
REALLY EVEN ETHICAL TO CONTINUE
DOING THE TRIAL IF IT IS
POTENTIALLY AS GOOD AS IT
SOUNDS.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS BEEN MISSING ALL ALONG,
RIGHT?
I'M NOT SAYING -- THIS IS NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR VACCINES,
THEY'RE MOST IMPORTANT THING
HERE.
EARLY ON BEFORE THE VACCINE
EVERYONE WAS HOPING THERE WOULD
BE SOME MIRACLE DRUG THAT COULD
KE YOU OUT OF E HOSPITAL IF
YOU CAUGHT COVID.
>> YEAH.
IT IS REALLY INTERESTING, JOHN.
JUST HISTORICALLY WE THINK ABOUT
ANTIBIOTICS, LOTS OF ANTIBIOTICS
FOR BACTERIAL INFECTIONS.
AS FAR AS ANTIVIRALS FOR VIRAL
INFECTIONS, IN THE WORD OF
HIV/AIDS, THAT'S WHERE IT HAS
BEEN STUDIED.
TAMIFLU, YOU KNOW, BUT NEVER
REALLY BEEN THE BIG ANTIVIRAL
PUSH.
NEVER REALLY BEEN A LOT OF
FUNDING FOR IT.
EVERY TIME SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS, A POTENTIAL VIRAL
OUTBREAK THERE IS RENEWED
INTEREST AND IT KIND OF FIZZLES
HAVING COVERED THIS FOR 20
YEARS.
HERE NOW YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF
PRODUCTS, THIS IS THE ONE FROM
MERCK, THERE IS ANOTHER ONE FROM
PFIZER THAT IS ALSO BEING
INVESTIGATED.
THAT SORT OF ALL ALONG WAS BEING
STUDIED.
AND THE THOUGHT WAS, LOOK, IT IS
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO COME IN
TIME FOR IT PANDEMIC.
BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE A VACCINE OR
SOMETHING ELSE, THE PANDEMIC
WILL SORT OF END BY THE TIME
THESE ANTIVIRALS GET DEVELOPED.
HERE WE ARE, YOU KNOW, AT THE
END OF 2021, STILL WITH A
TREMENDOUS NEED FOR THIS.
AS YOU CORRECTLY MENTIONED, THE
VACCINE PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM
GETTING THE ILLNESS IN THE FIRST
PLACE, THIS WOULD BE TO TREAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE MILDLY ILL,
MODERATELY ILL, TO KEEP THEM
FROM GETTING INTO THE HOSPITAL.
VERY IMPORTANT POTENTIALLY,
ESPECIALLY IN PLACES WHERE THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH VACCINE OR
COUNTRIES WHERE PEOPLE AREN'T
WILLING TO TAKE THE VACCINE.
>> HOW DOES THIS CHANGE THE
SCENARIO GOING FORWARD?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT ALL THE HYPE
AROUND HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, THE
REASON THERE WAS HYPE, COULD YOU
GIVE SOMETHING TO PEOPLE WHO
WERE MILDLY, MODERATELY ILL, A
PILL THEY COULD TAKE AT HOME AND
PREVENT THEM FROM GOING TO THE
HOSPITAL.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT IS A PIPE
DREAM, REMDESIVIR CAME CLOSE,
BUT FURTHER TRIAL RESULTS DID
NOT SHOW IT AS PROMISING.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WAS
PROBLEMATIC, HARMFUL TO
PATIENTS.
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES WAS THE
ONLY THING THAT COULD DO THAT,
REQUIRES AN INFUSION, ABOUT
2,000 BUCKS A DOSE.
HERE YOU TALK ABOUT FIVE DAYS,
TWICE A DAY OF A PILL THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY WHAT IT DOES, IT
BASICALLY INTERFERES WITH HOW
THE VIRUS REPLICATES.
YOU HAVE THE VIRUS IN YOUR BODY,
IT IS REPLICATING, THIS COMES IN
AND IN VARIOUS WAYS STOPS THAT
REPLICATION PROCESS FROM
HAPPENING.
SO IF IT WORKS, AND, AGAIN, LOTS
OF IFS HERE, BECAUSE THE FDA HAS
TO LOOK AT THIS, REMDESIVIR HAD
A LOT OF PROMISE AS WELL.
THIS SOUNDS REALLY PROMISING,
ANALYZED.
IF IT WORKS, THIS IS SOMETHING
PEOPLE COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE IN
THEIR HOMES, TAKE AFTER THEY GET
A POSITIVE TEST BEFORE THEY GET
REALLY SICK AND CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THEIR DISEASE.
>> "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
CALLS IT TAMIFLU FOR COVID.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY ANTIVIRAL WE
THINK ABOUT OUTSIDE OF THE WORLD
OF HIV/AIDS, TAMIFLU.
IT COULD USHER IN A NEW ERA WHEN
IT COMES TO ANTIVIRALS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS ANTIBIOTICS.
MOST PEOPLE COULDN'T NAME A
SINGLE ANTIVIRAL THIS WOULD BE
THE FIRST ONE THEY COULD EVER
NAME.
>> DON'T GO FAR.
YOU'LL